non mais non mais non chacun de
ses pas mal mais pas mal d'accord c'est
pas vrai décalé le portable ces boîtes a
gagné c'est pas grave chaka chaka
travail avec son matériel altima de
sutton quand ariane
les mecs c'est guillaume genton qui
passe mais de justesse de justesse le
juste tu gardes ton parc avec un cadeau
de noël comme le casque
[Applaudissements]
personnes il sera opposé à raymond le
contact mais ça va mon chéri et vous ça
va mais toi de faire tu voyais que des
foyers quoi tu m'a ramené coislin
celui avec lequel je travaille
j'ai dansé
oui c'est ça d'avoir besoin de toi ah
ouais
moi c'est marx mars voyant une farce max
oui j'adore la barre comme la tomate
comme chocolat
et
bien c'est bah je suis célibataire non
c'est vrai tu cherches quoi bah je
cherchais à m'amuser attendu tu veux ken
qualif au style de fille
or mon style défi on va dire m 80
d'accord chantal ont bien sûr d'accord
avec huawei avait 87 ans c'est
là qu'à appeler la 1 2 minutes on a
senti mal et c'est ton style on va dire
il faut déjà que je vais te regarde club
adacore donc tu ne sais pas qui c'est on
s'est tu sais tu sais où tu es
[Rires]
quand la mort frappe à ta pas
on sera là alors elle est très jolie
ouais alors non non non non je 30 ans
ici
j'ai dit si l'amour n'a pas d'âge
j'ai eu mes chéris j'avais alors mon
chéri tu vas jouer pour un cadeau qu'est
ce qui te fait plaisir tu veux le tu
vois là tu veux la plancha tu veux quoi
ça s'est un peu relou sait pas compter
sur toi pour un célibataire tu vas leur
dis maintenant dit aujourd'hui oui
j'aime bien aller m'a dit tu vas jouer
contre eux guillaume raymond tu connais
vraiment de chauffe
tu prend dès le 26 octobre est
d'accord et sympa ton sac il échappe à
ton sac
n'hésite pas alors c'est fort ce que je
fais en cfa
[Applaudissements]
oui le mec et premier degré et jean
gatty non
alors on n'est pas là pour ça on y pense
on n'est pas là pour ça je tente quand
même non je t'offre temps même bon nom
n'y a pas de femmes
c'est quoi ça
sert
[Applaudissements]
au
salut on va les cherry hill et kjeller
est que ces conneries là il est 18h30 on
envoie les derniers dernier passage et
après comme ça je donnais des cadres
tout le monde comme ça comment ça va toi
tu t'appelles quête chasse à l'homme à
caceres katia qui va sûrement nous voir
aussi un amour j'adore sa machine savez
quoi dans la vie je travaille dans les
ressources humaines j'adore y en a
beaucoup de deux ans qui ont besoin de
ressources ici que tu humanité donc tu
va peut-être nous servir des attaches
très content de te voir parce que tu es
un amour à chaque fois tu vas nous voir
et elle est très très peur mais si tu es
célibataire est célibataire mais qu'est
ce que tu recherches ben ça viendra non
c'est noël c'est l'amour c'est comme le
cache cache tu trouves pas tu trouves tu
cherches pas tu trouves pas non mais
c'est vraiment ça c'est de
patrick fiori
vache à lait qu'est ce que qu'elle est
considéré qu est ce qu on a peut-être
quelque chose qui potter bat g de la gfa
dit-il en particulier un oui ça dépend
un peu de la versalité c'est vrai ouais
c'est quoi le shilling chroniqueur
thérapie qui ont préféré
aller on va passer au jeu
non c'est pas vrai c'est pas ton délire
d'accord très bien donc voila merci à
vous merci katia de mettre les gens en
confiance ça fait extrêmement plaisir
bah tu vas jouer contre eux benjamin
castadi choisi contre-culture jouer des
rencontres
benjamin tu as énormément de gens du xxi
front tu es contre benjamin tu as bien
raison faut que tu as bien raison
attention c'est parti pour jouer
pourquoi matchs avec elfi très plaisir
tu veux quoi
telle est la télé aller la télé si tu
gagnes tu pars accès
[Applaudissements]
direct à bastia attendait calme-toi la
talbot voilà calme ça qui suit l'attaqué
mais
attention allez allez vas-y casta diva
[Applaudissements]
retenu la télé
d'un quelconque l'animera vanille
snobait tu mets ça dans le tas les
chéris maintenant on va jouer pour tous
les budgets tout le public aura des
cadeaux
au plateau où le public en plateau et
tous ceux qui sont sur un plateau et non
mais la m qui se dit à grande championne
de ce genre à jouer avec moi deux points
gagnants si ben gagnent tout le public
ne partira pas en vacances
si je gagne en de quoi c'est moi qui
gagne vous partirez aller d'accor s'y
met à l'avant ont préféré que ce soit
béni oui oui vous
allez benhabib à jouer pour vous et moi
je vais jouer ce que c'est vrai que
c'est moi le gardien le gardien du
temple allez mes gardiens de l'argent
benhaim s'étend de points gagnants
attention je rappelle
qu'au ps qu'on peut prendre ça s'il vous
plaît merci les mecs je ne peux pas tout
faire cette émission chez tous les jours
j'en ai marre allez on y va ben haim tu
va démarrer je commence oui j'ai un
petit galop d'essai pour voir aller à
galop d'essai allez vas-y qu'un statut
va nous pas nous soucier des doigts la
force et à l'est
g cham merci j'ai c'est louche a bien
fêté notre côté on
[Rires]
s'accroche ça m'a coupé
les riches des riches au la libye
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je rappelle que c'est en deux points et
six médailles ne gagnent en deux points
vous partirez en vacances sinon personne
ne part si c'est moi qui viennent
[Applaudissements]
tu es moi j'ai pas contrôler la partie
cette sorte de l'atacama
salesi ma'afu est le salaire n'est pas
sorti heaven hell pas grandi alors on
refait s'il voulait on refait on refait
alors n'auront pour valérie savait qu'il
a si ça passe c'est bon pas sûr cela
réel à cavani fait le
0 0
a offert entre autres et benhaim mais
tout bascule et chauray mais même ce
quota facile jusqu'au bout de la table
m'a dit non alors tout
[Applaudissements]
lors d'un duel à sortir alors on n'a pas
loin de se dire ça alors on l'a fait à
résister alors mais il faut la sentir
qu'à la sortie québec c'est comme au
pénal quand usain bolt sur le mal et le
point 3 % alors on a droit de sortir ou
pas fait le poids jaffe le poisson saut
allez on va à 37,6 cause du risque a
raté leur chance alors libérer jafar
hilali je peux payer ce sera la dana
fois à l'e mail ou basé mon
mari valérie
blais ont des mois son téléphone sonne
alors c'est pas malin avec le poids du
corps
des victimes
civiles et hier après la deuxième audi
que ça compte pas aller vous quand vous
avez cassé la tête
mais les mecs ne crois pas que ça c'est
sur un toit sur la femme
la vallée
[Applaudissements]
c'est toi mais alors si ça sort est ce
que ça compte ou pas oui non dites moi
cette fois-ci ok d'accord reçu l'amendé
si ça sorte si ça sort cpo cote si je
gagne là ça fait 2-0 ya pas de cadeau
bravo c'est à ça sort par
là s'est pas tapé fort moyen d'aller à
l'audace et la point décisif ok trois
des six alors là ça sens où ça sent pas
de jeu c'est la sortie
pas de sortie donc je suis désavantagés
oui je suis d en découvrir davantage
allez valérie profond que ça à faire
[Applaudissements]
besoin nous t'avions des
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
essuie mains
disait pas ça hier soir le
hajj est passé hier soir
si je gagne les cherry a pas de cadeaux
et bien sûr j'offrirai tous les voyages
à ma famille
la famille hanouna j'embrasse s'est
battu pendant des années
la tunisie jusqu'à la france vont en
être là et ils partiront aussi s'éclater
dans les différents pays du monde
pendant que les benhaim seront
tranquillement chez eux à broyer du noir
les gars si tu peux dire cela qui va
sortir
je te le dis je te le dis venez
[Applaudissements]
là ce genre